die Bananen die wir heute essen sind
nicht die einzige Sorte die es jemals
gab früher gab es die graum Michelle
oder auch dicker Michel das war eine
beeindruckende 500 g schwere Banane die
weniger Druckstellen bekam und angeblich
sogar besser geschmeckt hat als unsere
heutige kevinischbanane aber was ist da
passiert dass sie plötzlich von der
Bildfläche verschwand nun in der ersten
Hälfte des 20 Jahrhunderts wurde die
Grom Michelle von der Panama Krankheit
heimgesucht die durch den Pilz Fusarium
oxysporum forma speziale kubense
verursacht wird damals war es die fog
Variante tropical Race 1 die der Grom
Michelle den Todesstoß versetzte seit
spätestens 1960 ist diese köstliche
Bananensorte praktisch nicht mehr auf
dem Markt erhältlich das ist nicht nur
eine traurige Geschichte für die Grom
Michelle sondern auch eine Warnung für
unsere geliebte kevinish Banane denn
genau wie ihre Vorgängerin ist auch die
kevinish von der Panama Krankheit
bedroht nur das ist heute die fog
Variante tropical Race vier ist die sich
weltweit ausbreitet vielleicht ist auch
diese Sorte bald Geschichte denn